The Joe Rogan Experience way back when
before I got sober I had this tour the
it was called the don't try this at home
tour and I would promote every show by
saying I will be drunk and on drugs or
your money back
and I'm in it and and you you watched me
what year was this that it started in
2001 and and I ran that
until like 2005. and um and and uh I
mean you just watch me get completely
hammered on stage like pounding tequila
and [ __ ] when I came out on stage I
would walk out with like a suitcase of
Budweiser cans and I'd toss them out of
the crowd and I would take the can I'd
start out with one and and I would just
bash my head with it until the can
exploded and I'd be particularly proud
if the can broke into two separate
pieces and after I broke the one can
then I would take out two cans of one in
each hand and go back and forth
and and break both of them um so I would
every show I would break three beers
over my head and uh I would do that like
every night oh my God and and and and
and that like what what I understand
about the CTE phenomenon is that you're
absolutely right it's not about how hard
you get hit it's it's the the
accumulation of lots of little hits and
that's why my ball is the biggest one
did you suffer anything from that the
worst part was then then like after I
got sober started doing stand up like
initially there there was a period where
I would do it with sparkling water cans
and you were doing it still you started
eating yourself in the head I did it for
a little while and uh how many times you
think you've beaten yourself in the head
how many shows if you had to count them
all up uh hundreds
oh my God right and I mean as far as I
can tell I I I'm in pretty good shape
maybe Tony Hawk told me one time he had
he says that um
that he found out with regard to CTE
that there's a gene which which will
make you predisposed to Alzheimer's
disease apoe4 yeah yeah and if you have
that Gene then you're you're very much
at risk for CTE but if you don't have
that Gene you're considerably less at
risk and he said that when he found that
out he went and got the test and and
determined that he did not have that
Gene and and and when I heard that like
kind of chewed on it for a while I ended
up like like it was It was kind of kind
of nagging at me and I ended up like
reaching back out to Tony I said hey
Tony about that test like what was your
what was your plan if you did have the
gene okay you can't understand yourself
in the head right you know and he's like
oh well I didn't have a plan I'm like
well how can you have a plan after the
fact right exactly but so I'm like I I
don't want to [ __ ] go take that test
I don't want to know if I have that
goddamn gene or not well if it's been
this many years afterwards you're not
suffering you probably don't have that
Gene I also went to like and now of
course famously the the whole CTE
phenomenon you can't find out if you
have it until you've died and they've
like I think they can tell now oh yeah
yeah I think there's a new way that they
can tell before you die but it used to
be the head of weight and do an autopsy
on you right well I went to some like
brain specialist kind of guy were you
having problems no know I just went
because I was interested and uh doc Dr
Drew sent me to this guy it was actually
when I was uh the the and I was trying
to get cauliflower here as like as part
of part of uh my multimedia comedy and I
remember telling you too that I was like
I'm gonna do a crazy bit and I tried to
get cauliflower here and I remember you
telling me that uh you were like nope I
don't support that he said I think the
cauliflower ear is something that should
be earned you know like and uh I
remember thinking oh well like
I I I became buddies with Chuck Liddell
and uh Chuck Liddell and I got together
we made the [ __ ] funniest craziest
video like uh of him trying to get like
I I I I I got I made this helmet that
like I designed this helmet that left my
ears sticking out so it would protect my
head from like head shots
a little bit and my ears sticking out
and and I got Chuck Liddell [ __ ] sets
uh a golf ball on my ear and [ __ ] Wax
It Off
did you get cauliflower here that no
that then
um that we'd spent two days with Chuck
trying to do it and and it just didn't
work then I got together with Ronda
Rousey and and was on the mats with her
and she's like her hand and Travis just
like roughing a mirror all day long and
and and and uh and they're looking at my
ear they're like dude we got it that's
it you know we got it and then it just
went away then I got together with Jorge
masvedol he put his uh his uh BMF belt
over my ear and he's just like punching
it against it a door and uh and he's
like dude that's it right there man
that's cauliflower we got it it didn't
and then then I got together with Jon
Jones oh my God I had like the who's who
you're such a glutton for punishment
who's who of the UFC Hall of Fame like
give their best shot and everybody said
dude we got it and then it didn't work
dude Jon Jones blasted my ear into
Oblivion like oh where the phone he took
uh what at the time was his current
light heavyweight belt
and like
oh yeah Jesus Christ and he's hammering
your ear dude oh my God he's so
upsettingly overdid it that my ear got
got blasted apart and you still didn't
get cauliflower oh God it's so bloody
oh my god dude what the [ __ ] we're not
putting that up get that you just
chipped it off you didn't get stitched
up ah just cut that little piece off
dropped it off oh no yeah so you have
like the Evander Holyfield
right when Tyson bit Holyfield's here
right okay that was that was an idea
that I pitched for Jackass like uh
multiple times I was like do I want like
Mike Tyson to buy the chocolate oh no oh
my God